كان توظيف مزدهرا وكان موظفوه تكنولوجيا
يفخرون بالقيمه العاليه لقطاعها لكن قبل
عام اصبح المشهد مختلفا بشكل ملحوظ فلم
تحقق واحده من اكثر من 15 شركه تقنيه
امريكيه قيمتها عوائد جميله في المجموعه
خسر المستثمرون ما يقرب من 7.4 تريليون
دولار بناءا على انخفاض الذي دعم 12 شهرا
في مؤشر ناسك واليوم تعملوا شركات على خفض
التكاليف والتجميد التعيينات الجديده
وتسريحا والسؤال هنا عن الحجم الاخطاء في
الصناعات التكنولوجيا
الاجابه تكمل في الرهان الخاصه على فيروس
كورونا الذي لم يغير للابد طرق العمل
واللعب والتسوق والتعلم عن بعد خسائر
القطاع بالارقام معك على
لميس لميس
فقدت اسهم بعد شركات التكنولوجيا اكثر من
50 بالمئه من قيمتها السوقيه خلال الفتره
الماضيه بينما اعلنت عن تسريح نسب كبيره
من موظفيها ولا يبدو ان اي من هذه الشركات
افلتت من الازمه الرهينه واليكم الارقام
700 مليار دولار مخسرتهم مايكروسوفت من
قيمتها السوقيه اما متى فغسلت اكثر من 600
مليار دولار هذا العام اي ما يعادل 70% من
قيمتها تقريبا ريفيه عن شركه السيارات
الكهربائيه انخفضت اسومها باكثر من 80%
بعد ان بلغ سقها اكثر من مئه وخمسين مليار
دولار امازون بدورها خسرت تريليون دولار
من قيمتها السوقيه لتصبح اول شركه تخسر
هذا الكم من القيمه السوقيه كما تراجعها
صندوق رنا سينس للطرح العام الاولي وهو
سلم من الشركات الامريكيه المدرج الحديثه
بنسبه 57% خلال العام الماضي
والى منصه التويتر من جديد هذه المنصه
التي اصبحت منبر الاعلاميه لكبار
المسؤولين والمنظمات الذين ينشرون بيناتهم
الرسميه هناك خلال اقل من 15 عاما احدثت
هذه المنصه تغييرا كبيرا في الصحافه
ايجابيا من وجهه نظر كثيرين وسلبيا في نظر
المنتقدين ومع الخطر الذي يتحدث تويتر
237 مليون مستخدم فالكثير من الصحفيين
يتواصلون على تويتر مع الجهات التي توفر
لهم معلومات سواء من الخبراء او السياسيين
بينما يرى اخرون ان تويتر تدمر الصحافه
خاصه بما تثيره بعض التغريدات
بدون نظر الى الامور من زوايا اخرى
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا الخبير المختص في تكنولوجيا
الاعمال دكتور انس
اكثر من رونالدو
الى فعلا ركود فيك كثير من القطاعات لكن
التواصل نقل المعلومات هذا الشيء اساسي
ودائما سوف يبقى واي تقنيه تدعم وتساعد في
نشر هذه الخدمات اكيد سوف تبقى شيء اساسيه
خلينا نحكي بصراحه احنا عصعيد ناس عاديين
ومستخدمين كل هالجدل الحاصل مؤخره وحاول
كبار همم عالمتك نحن كمستخدمين عاديين هل
نتاثر لان لحد الان انا لم المس هذا
التغيير وهذا التاثر بوجود ماسك او عدمه
يعني طبعا لهم ماسك هو طبعا بطريقه ادارته
بطريقه سوف يعمل تغييرات داخليه شركه داخل
الشركه هذا طبعا قد يؤثر على نوعيه
الخدمات التي او الاضافات التي سوف نحصل
عليها نحن كمستخدمون بالنهايه ولكن هذا
يحصل في يوم وليله
التغيرات الاداريه سوف تؤدي الى التغيرات
الاستراتيجيه في خصائص هذه الان الاشياء
اللي راح يصير انه راح تصبح مثلا بعض
الخدمات مدفوعه هتصبح بعض الخدمات بعض
الاشخاص عندهم الحق وعندهم اذا دفعوا
والاشتراك ووسعوا حساباتهم وهذا حصل طبعا
يعني يعملوا بلبله يعني انت حلو شخصيات
وهذا فعلا يعني عنده التاثيرات كبيره على
قطاعات صحيه يعني وايضا ادى الى خساره
ونزول قيمه السوقيه لشركات خلال يعني فتره
بسيطه فهنالك اثر كبير حقيقه يعني تراجع
صناعه التكنولوجيا هل كان لاسباب داخليه
ركبها القطاع يا دكتور ام عوامل خارجيه
طبعا العوامل الخارجيه بلا شك هي ما
يقدرنس وهي تؤثر بشكل كبير على يعني نقل
على الاستثمارات ويعني رغبه المستثمرين في
وضع تعرف المستثنى دائما يخاف اذا حصل
ايوترات بسيطه في قطاعات معينه قد يذهب
الى ربما نوع اخر من الاستثمار ولكن لا
استطيع ان اقول هذه النهايه بالعكس هذه
فتره بسيطه ممكن بعدها تعيد الشركات
التكنولوجيه وضع سياسات الاستثماريه بشكل
افضل بما يتواصل بما يتناسب مع اولويات
الناس اليوميه يعني خدمات تنجح لانها تقدم
خدمات ضروريه مهمه صح طيب خلينا تكنولوجيا
مع الخبر الذي همم يشير بانه الصحفي هو
الخاسر الاكبر مما يحصل في تويتر اليوم من
الصحفيون الذين يعملون في مؤسسات اعلاميه
اعتبروا بان تويتر برزهم عصايه شخصي قبل
ارتباطهم باسم المؤسسه واعتمدوا ايضا بشكل
كبير على المعلومات من خلال تويتر وطرح
المعلومه بشكل حصري اليوم ما مستقبل هؤلاء
الى اين يلجئون وما هي البدائل يعني طبعا
التكنولوجيا اثرت بشكل كبير على قطاع
الصحافه واداء عمليه يعني جمع المعلومات
يعني تويتر هو المميز في انه اغلب
السياسيين والمشاهير موجودين في وبالتالي
مصدر سهل وسريع للصافيين صحفيين يبدو انه
لازم يستخدم همم
التقنيات جديده ويستخدم ايضا طرق جديده في
جمع المعلومات والربما يتسلح بالذكاء
الاصطناعي والبقن والبيج دايت اناليتيكس
ويحاولوا انه يعني يتعلم هذه التولز
الجديده التي ممكن من خلالها يعني يستقرئ
معلومات دقيقه وايضا طبعا العمل التقليدي
الصحفي المهني هذا الشيء اساسي وهو تحري
الدقه يعني لا نستطيع ان نقول انه اي
تغريده على تويتر هي تمثل 100% الواقع
وبالتالي متحرك دقه والنصادر مختلفه وايضا
تواصل مع الناس همم باساليب اخرى وقد تكون
اساليب غير تويتر يعني قد يكون شيء همم
اساسي انا لا اعتقد انهم خاسر الاكبر ربما
سوف يضطر الى التعلم اشياء جديده وتغير
طبعا هذا قد يكون مؤلم او مزعج الى حد معه
شكرا جزيلا يعني المختص في التكنولوجيا
العمل شكرا
[موسيقى]